questions
[Music]
foreign
good good evening
good to see each one of you glad that
you are here welcome to the table
my name is Don Jacobs I am one of the
elders no that sounds weird here
um so I'm glad that you glad everyone
could join us tonight thank you for
those who are being able to join us
online you are very much a part of this
community even though we can't
physically see you but we're glad that
you're here as well
uh just a couple quick announcements uh
before we get started with everything so
tonight we are doing our say the table
meeting
it's going to be online it's going to be
a little bit different than what we've
done uh previously but it is kind of
like our state you know kind of like the
State of the Union but just specifically
about table
um things so it's gonna be at seven
o'clock tonight you can you know go home
turn around dinner put the kids to bed
have it kind of playing and all that
kind of stuff that would be great
um so you get again get to kind of hear
things that we normally talk about at
the say the table
um you know Stefan changes his
leadership some of our goals that we
have out for the rest of the year some
Financial things and just different
announcements we have just moving
forward so make sure you just tune in if
you need the link you can talk to Brett
or myself
um we can only pass that out and make
sure you have that before you walk out
the door so we want to make sure you
have that
um the other thing a quick announcement
is that there is a new Meetup that's
going to be happening in the Wiley area
so um yeah yeah I heard some Applause in
the background love that
um so it's gonna be with uh Raymond and
or excuse me Ramon and Miranda Delgado
they are leading that so if that's
something that you are interested in hi
there they are
it's going to be Wednesdays um at seven
and so they if you had something you're
interested in if you would like like to
let us know there's cards in the back as
you're walking out I'm just kind of just
kind of say hey I'm interested in that
just let us know and we can make sure we
connect you to them directly or you can
yeah just Miranda go talk to her should
be great she's a great person to talk to
anyway with that being said I'm going to
pray real quick and we'll get started
with worship
Lori thank you so much for this evening
thank you for this the people in this
room uh people who are online and
watching and participating that way
thank you for just the just being able
to come here and be present no matter
what we've had going on this week no
matter what stresses that we may have
walked in the door with
fears anxieties or anything that's been
weighing on us thankful that we can come
here and be able to just lay them at
your feet and hopefully just get some
level of wisdom some level of comfort
and some level of Grace and peace I pray
you just be with us rest of this evening
open up our hearts and Minds to Worship
in the things that we share tonight in
Christ Simon Christ's names I pray amen
amen thanks Don will you guys stand to
your feet with us if you would like we
are going to start out tonight with a
song called Springtime because who knows
what this weather is going to hold we
may be in the dead of winter tomorrow or
we may be in summer but let's set our
sights on new things that God is doing
New Life
um and Grace for each moment that it
brings
[Music]
you're the resurrection
that we've waited for
you bury the night
and came with the morning
you're the king of Heaven
all the praise is yours
the longer the quiet
the louder the core is
foreign
[Music]
you're the Living Water
God we thirst for you the dry and the
bearing
will Blossom and blue
you're the sun that's shining
you restore my soul
the deeper you call
using a new song cause death is dead and
gone with the winner we will sing a new
song that Hallelujah
we're coming back to life we're reaching
towards the light your love is like
springtime
[Music]
comes in the soil
comes in the soil of my soul and like a
garden
and like a garden I will grow
I will grow
sing that together content
the soil
comes in the soil
and like a garden
and like a garden I will grow
foreign
[Music]
all right you kiddos are dismissed to
your classrooms we will see you after
the service
thanks for singing with us
thank you kids ministry workers again
for all that you do to love on these
kids to point them towards the way of
Jesus
would not be a working thriving
Community without you
y'all are awesome
[Music]
[Applause]
we're going to go ahead and transition
into
the prayers of the people now most of
you know the routine but if this is one
of your first times here please read
this prayer aloud with us or we invite
you to do that if you'd like and then
we're going to leave some space for you
to share what's being carried on your
heart whatever is heavy in your life
right now if there's a person or a
situation that is Weighing on you we
just invite you to share those with us
even online in the comments share them
and we will just hold space for that
together and lift each other's burdens
up before God and then we will finish
out with the closing prayer together
would you guys pray this with me for the
city of Sachse Texas and for every city
and community and all who live in them
we pray to you
for The Good Earth you have given us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it we pray to you for the old and the
sick for the Widow and orphan for the
injured and suffering we pray to you for
the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for the
vulnerable the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you
Lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to you
and Jeff and their family
foreign
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
amen
Jessie's gonna teach us a song that we
haven't done before in this context I'm
not sure if you may have heard it but
it's called the cross has the final word
and I just wanted to say going into it
um
that
the encouragement I take from these
lyrics is just that no matter what
you're facing God has something better
and there is a cross that bore the
weight of our pain
so allow him to carry that for you and
believe that he is with you in it that
he has walked this road that he has seen
our suffering and experienced it
firsthand
and at the end there was Resurrection
there was New Life there was healing and
transformation and hope that we didn't
even have for ourselves so let's believe
that for each other and for ourselves
[Music]
the cross has a fine word
the cross has
sorrow May Come
his Darkest Night
the cross
[Music]
the cross has
but the cross
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you foreign
[Music]
carefully
itself
[Music]
there's nothing stronger
nothing higher
nothing greater than the name of Jesus
no
love the power
and all the glory to the name of Jesus
something stronger
nothing higher
nothing greater than the name of Jesus
[Music]
followed
foreign
[Music]
because
[Applause]
you do yes you do you need
[Music]
foreign
walking around these walls
I thought right now they'd fall
but you have never
failed me yet
[Music]
waiting for change to come
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm still in your hands this is my
confidence
you've never failed me
[Music]
ant
I know that night won't last
[Music]
your word will come to pass
my heart will sing your praise again
[Music]
Jesus You're Still Enough
keep me within your
love
my heart will sing your praise again
[Music]
your promise still stands great is your
faithfulness faith
fullness
I'm still in your hands this is
[Music]
still stands great is your
faithfulness faithfulness
I'm still in your hands this is my
confidence
[Music]
never failed me yet
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
you move the mountains
where there was no way
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll see you do it again
[Music]
do it again
your promise still stands great is your
faithfulness faithfulness
I'm still in your hands this is my
confidence
you've never failed me yet foreign
[Music]
God you are faithful
you meet us
in every situation
at our best and at our worst God you are
there
you carry us through
[Music]
God would we look to you would we Center
on you
[Music]
would we trust your goodness
your forgiveness your Redemption
to keep doing its good work in our heart
[Music]
would you make us into the children of
God you created us to be
would we become more like Jesus
[Music]
would we choose your love and your path
even when it isn't easy
even when it kills our ego
God would you show us a better way
[Music]
we need your love
we need that work in our hearts
thank you for not giving up on us
[Music]
thank you for this time together God we
celebrate it
we appreciate it
[Music]
in Jesus name we ask these things
amen you guys turn and welcome the
people around you and then we will get
started on our message
oh Grace and peace it is uh good to be
with you all my name is Brett and um
yeah it's just it's wonderful to
to be together to worship Christ to
re-center at uh at the end of a long I'm
sure for many of you a long crazy week
and it's nice to have a moment to
breathe before going into the next one
so
um yeah all that to say I'm really
really glad that you're here and
um as always that includes those joining
us online love you all lots and um and
anyone here who's new thanks for for
joining us being with us I know it can
take a lot of Courage walk through those
doors so thank you for being here
um so let's see today is the first
Sunday of Lent
not the first day of lint that kicked
off at our Ash Wednesday service which a
few of you are out so thanks for being
here or being there
um and uh so for those unfamiliar the
season of Lent it's basically like the
40-day uh time of kind of heart uh mind
soul preparation just spiritual
preparation as we uh come into
um the day of the Cross which is Good
Friday and then on to Easter Sunday so
um it's it's really I mean it's a really
special time in in the church calendar
and we love to just occasionally we
don't always follow the church calendar
like super strictly but we just kind of
we jump on uh for all the big Seasons
you know Advent leading up to Christmas
and uh and now lent so I do love those
times to um join in with the broader
church and just to remember like we're
not alone
um you know there's
um yeah whole whole communities of folks
and I mean tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of churches all over the world
that are joining in right now
um in the same season so there's
something really really cool about that
um I will say I encourage you to you
know as best you can like really be here
and engage this season because there is
something so powerful about engaging the
season of Lent as we go into Easter it's
and it just it makes the whole Good
Friday and then Easter experience so
much richer and more profound like when
you've taken time to actually reflect
for a minute I don't know if in the past
especially um uh if you've you know been
a part of a church that didn't do
something like lent like it's easy to
kind of just like for Easter to sneak up
on you you ever had that experience like
oh Easter Sunday is the Sunday like Oh
Praise the Lord you know and it's just
sort of like you did it's almost like um
uh like I was even thinking of folks who
will you know tend to kind of show up to
church on Easter you know having maybe
not been there like since maybe
Christmas you know and um and I was
thinking like it's a little bit like uh
I mean on the one hand I'm like super
glad they're there I'd rather them be
there for Easter than not at all yeah
that's a win
um but on the other hand it's a bit like
telling a friend like hey I wanted um
let's go see that movie they're like
okay awesome and then you like show up
just for the last 15 minutes and they're
like hey what happened I thought you're
gonna come to the movie like wow I just
wanted the happy part you know and uh
there's something about we kind of like
a movie isn't Rich if you don't kind of
go through the whole process you know
and it's the similar with engaging the
story like you kind of need like to
experience the weightiness of the Cross
and have some
um
uh like kind of go through some of the
the Heartbreak go through some of the
um the pain so that we can have the
Breakthrough in the celebration and the
Hallelujah you know otherwise it's sort
of a thin Hallelujah you know it just
doesn't have the the weightiness behind
it so all that to say I hope you'll um
engage this this season um with us I
also wanted to mention
um it's normal in the season of Lent to
um either fast something that is like
give something up
um or and or
um to like engage in new spiritual
practice uh you know so it could be
um you know saying like maybe you're
kind of a person who tends to have like
a short prayer time or something in the
morning and maybe you like add one at
lunch you know or you read the
scriptures before you go to bed or
something like some practice you can
kind of engage a new practice or you can
give something up uh you know folks
often do like chocolate something they
love I think ultimately though whatevs
you know it's like whatever whatever
it's different for every person the um
the thing that they know like yeah maybe
this is like either a sacrifice or it's
maybe even something kind of unhealthy
like not it's sort of holding you back
you know and so um this is it's normal
to kind of fast um that thing and of
course Sundays technically you don't
have to continue fast that's sort of
like the Lord's day and so
um usually you can celebrate on Sundays
but um at any rate so let's see we are
beginning a new series uh tonight
titled lint the way of the Cross and uh
we're going to be taking the next few
Sundays to
um just kind of reflect
um on this on this theme and I want to
mention throughout the series I'm going
to be drawing from a book
um titled the crucifixion by Fleming
Rutledge and uh you've got an image of
it it is if you're looking for like uh
like something meaty and for theology
all two of you maybe more I don't know
um in this Linton season you're like oh
yes what I want is a 600 page book on
the cross well oh my gosh my friends
it's right there it's on Amazon
um you can borrow my copy while I'm
using it for the series um which is why
I bring it up so
um it is it really is I love uh Fleming
around she has done like this is a book
it took her 20 years to write it and you
can tell like it's not one of those that
like you know just fired off to the
Press like you can tell it is a profound
word what what Rutledge has done is
uh it's just so careful it's so nuanced
like and and ultimately she kind of I
mean I was offended she offends people
like she and she kind of offends
everyone whether you find yourself in a
more kind of political or a
theologically conservative place or a
theologically kind of more Progressive
you know she will kind of she will
challenge
she will she certainly challenged me
um because it's easy to kind of slip
into ways of um thinking about Christian
faith or theology that are kind of I
don't know it's like
it's easy to just kind of go with the
crowd whatever crowd you're in you know
just kind of like yeah that's what we
think I haven't really thought it
through but we just yeah that's what we
think you know
you know really good at like poking
um so I'm gonna be draw I mentioned it
because I'm gonna be um drawing from
this kind of throughout the series so I
just wanted to like full credit where
credit is due
um I've definitely am leaning heavily on
on old women Rutledge for this series so
with that um in mind the title of the
message tonight is the cross is what God
does
the cross is what God does our scripture
is going to be Romans chapter 3 verses
22 through 25.
and I should mention the second word is
the word righteousness which can throw
people off sometimes and this instance
it's kind of functioning like a like a
noun like an identity as a a healed
restored heal uh I just said healed
twice I'm awesome at preaching
um just a a um yeah Someone set right
before God so all right verse 22 this
righteousness is given through faith in
Jesus Christ
to all who believe
there is no difference between Jew and
Gentile
for all have sinned and fall short of
the glory of God and all are Justified
freely by his grace through the
Redemption that came by Christ Jesus
God presented Christ as a sacrifice of
atonement through the shedding of his
blood
to be received by faith
so I want to start here there's a a
quote from the poet T.S Eliot where he
said this
they are absorbed
in the endless struggle
to think well of themselves
and in in the context uh
uh Elliot is kind of really thinking of
folks who long to feel important that's
kind of like the setting of the poem but
I was kind of thinking like huh I wonder
if um if Elliot would like be okay with
me kind of broadening it out because I
when I think of kind of the Human family
often probably driven by our own
insecurities you know about
um our own struggles and shortcomings
and such I think we are often kind of
engaged in this the endless struggle uh
to think well of ourselves and
um
I think it takes up a lot of bandwidth
our time our energy convincing ourselves
at times sort of awkwardly trying to
convince others and even the way this
often plays out is
um kind of seeing like our own
shortcomings and
um sins and struggles as like a mistake
you know whereas for everyone else it's
like well they meant too you know like
it's in other words it's easy to kind of
project the evil out there we love to do
this often when we're getting very
tribal you know so we're the good people
and then all those other folks they need
to get it together don't they you know I
mean and that you can see where that
even preaches well preachers at times
very much slip into this right where
because that feels good for all of us to
feel real good about ourselves and then
uh to project the evil out but of course
it's not just communal or tribal it
happens as individuals you know where
it's like well I just I made a mistake
but those people
oh that's where the evil resides you
know
um
and uh it seems to me it's sort of a
rather forced
um kind of naive
a naive view of who we really are
um or at least what we're capable
of
and it's almost as though we have this
idea like
at times that like 2023 like this is
gonna be the year where if I just try or
super duper hard I'm gonna finally pull
it together just you wait everyone
and uh and it seems to me it just isn't
so we end up in a cycle that the
therapist Jeff Van vondrit vondren he
calls it the uh give up or the try
harder give up cycle
um it's also been called the like Purge
and binge cycle you know where you're
like you kind of go very extreme into
like okay I'm cleaning up my Act I'm
clean it's time you know and it can kind
of look all sorts of ways like it can
look like health-wise you know like
clear out the pantry you don't have to
raise your hand if you've ever done the
dramatic clear out the pantry you know
clear it out
you know and uh we're getting number
five
before we go or it can look you know
spiritually it can look
um even like in Christian faith context
like getting back to church I'm on it
and I'm joining that small group and I'm
doing you know I mean I'm having my
morning devotions and whatever like you
know so you get in this kind of which
isn't bad you know I mean it's I'm not
trying to mock that like there's a good
impulse there but often what van vondren
points out is it sort of like um and we
sort of overshoot like we we sort of
sell ourselves as like oh yeah I'm
getting it together everything I mean
you even kind of start talking a bigger
game than you can actually live you know
like all the things you're gonna do you
know what I mean and just it's sort of
we get in this try harder mode and we
kind of overshoot often exhaust
ourselves
you know sort of take on more than we're
realistically even capable of we exhaust
and then what do we do
and then it's the give up now I'm done I
don't even care
I don't even care about anything you
know I mean it's like every habit every
I mean it's can you see where it's like
dramatic you know I mean it's not like
subtle or like Yeah I'm
gonna that would maybe be healthier
instead it's these sort of Dramatics we
try harder give up you know
um
it's a it's a it's a problem and and I
think the way it plays out in Christian
faith
um this is something a friend and a
mentor of mine calls it our um our
self-improvement projects
you know
um
and there there can often be something
sort of
um
unhealthy in them which sounds weird I
get because like as Americans we're like
no this is what we're all about like the
whole self-help industry like this is
our Jam I mean if we're not trying to
get better what are we doing you know
and I'd see the truth in that like yeah
but there's some impul there's something
in it that's sort of
strikes me as like off a little bit so
I've been processing like what is it and
this is something that I'll try to sum
it up in this way until I come to the
end of myself
you ever had an experience of coming to
the end of yourself where it's like
you've tried it all
the 12-step folks know all about this
until I come to the end of myself
till my self-improvement projects all
turn to ashes
until I am laid Low by suffering
sometimes it's just life that hits us
until I'm shocked
not at others capacity for evil at my
own
oh that's a heck of a moment
until these things happen I do I just
don't get it I do not yet understand the
cross of Jesus Christ I am still trying
to save myself
there's an ancient Church
it's in the city of Bethlehem it's
called The Church in the nativity
and it's it's famous because
it's purported to kind of be in
Tradition
um it's built this church is built on
the very site where Christ himself was
born
and so you can imagine whether it's like
people making spiritual pilgrimages or
just tourists you know
um this is like a popular Church to
visit if you do the whole Holy Land you
know experience
um but there's a little uh Wrinkle in
the architecture of this church that I
haven't studied enough to know like was
it on purpose or I don't know but um
it's I mean it's completely genius
because to well the main entrance or the
only entrance
is um
built
at like just a shade under five feet
tall
and so if you want to enter this holy
place
what do you have to do
you have to you have to bow
you have to get low
I just I love this I think it's such a
genius image like is there something
about
um
our you know something that happens to
us when we do things with our bodies you
know like even prayer we've talked about
this where people will say like oh it
doesn't matter how you pray you know
just pray in any position you want you
know hands up and that's true like it's
not like God's like oh that's not the
proper prayer I'm not you know I mean
but but you can see where prayer changes
you know I mean a prayer like this
that's a sort of different prayer than
this you know what I mean like it's just
the body it's so you can imagine I love
this image
of thousands maybe tens of thousands of
people a year trying to to come to Jesus
to to enter this holy place and every
single one of them has to do what stoop
Get Low Bow
um Fleming Rutledge has this this to say
reflecting on Romans 3 our passage
um she said this Paul's gospel
is modeled
not on human possibility and potential
but on the power of God
Paul's gospel is model not on human
possibility and potential but on the
power of God it seems to me that we are
often very especially in our kind of
broader American culture very obsessed
with human possibility and potential
like like how strong how awesome how
powerful can we get
um
how how kind of how much can we
eliminate
or at least sort of ignore our fatal
flaws which maybe we're more prone to
ignore once the elimination doesn't work
you know
um
like it seems we're trying but to follow
Christ to believe the gospel
it begins with a stoop with a bow
with with a certain being brought low
and why is that it's because right at
the heart of Christian faith
is a cross
and that cross
is a powerful
statement because
this is what human beings are capable of
like when and again not to project the
evil out there like those human beings
though I can't believe what those folks
did two thousand years ago you know how
could they all those disciples fleeing
from Jesus you know I wouldn't have done
that I would have bravely stood you know
I mean you can see where we kind of want
to project the if it just doesn't work
does it like there's there's something
about the cross
that is a very powerful kind of a
sobering
um
statement
to us
and I might say it like this like
though it's true that we are fearfully
and wonderfully made
though it's true that we are loved down
to our toes
so it's absolutely true that I believe
even we are created good right in the
image of God
uh it's also true
that um
that messed upness
is it in you too
it's in me
it's in each of us isn't it
and that's why the cross is so powerful
but sobering and difficult
because
it's a reminder to us of that coming
back to verse 23 this is why Paul writes
for all have sinned and fallen short of
the glory of God
and notice it's not some have sinned
or well yes all have sinned but some
more than others you know and just
there's no qualification Jess
here we are all have sinned and fallen
short of the glory of God
um one very kind of poetic
sort of uh I mean it's funny but it's
also sort of a cutting metaphor that the
Bible is very fond of when it comes to
human beings and Jesus himself was very
fond of it uh is the metaphor of
um referring to us as a sheep
and which if you know anything about
sheep that is not a compliment
um she you know I mean while there is a
certain kind of
Frailty or innocence about them but on
the other hand they are uh dumb as
bricks they're just uh not the sharpest
you know and um so it's sort of a
strange metaphor like I think you know
for us we're like so far from an
agrarian society you know with Shepherds
whatever that I think we sort of lost on
us when Jesus is like referring to us
you know as the like the the 99 sheep
and then the one that wanders and I'll
I'll get you you know I mean it's just
it's all sort of lost on us but I think
for the first century here I think they
would have been like what you know like
it's a little offensive man you can't
talk about us like that we're not sheep
you know
um
but even the book of Isaiah uses this
metaphor we all like sheep have gone
astray each of us has turned his or her
own way but the lord has laid on him
that is Christ the iniquity the sin of
us all uh so it's just passages like you
know there's this sort of this thread
um but a few weeks ago my friend uh
Brandon he sent me this video uh it's
made the rounds on the socials so I'm
sure many of you have seen it
um but I thought it was a beautiful
picture of of what we're talking about
so let's go ahead and uh play the short
clip
[Music]
thank you
oh my goodness I love there's a comment
on the YouTube version of this because
of course it's on Instagram it's like
you know wherever you want to look but
the first comment was some actual
footage of Jesus rescuing me from my
horrible decisions
laughs
uh I think you know this is the message
of the Gospel right though fearfully and
wonderfully made though love down to our
toes though made in the image of God oh
my gosh what do we keep doing this you
know what I mean we just saved and then
we're like and just we're just we just
keep doing it
um
and
I think that's I would say that's the uh
the challenging news you know thanks be
to God there's a verse 24.
um while it's true all of sin didn't
fall short of the glory of God verse 24
says this and all
all
are Justified freely
by his grace through the Redemption that
came by Christ Jesus
to be justified that's to be declared as
righteous as holy as washed clean made
new
that's uh that's good news isn't it
and you might
Wonder
um
that little word all
you know that's quite a word
oh who's the all referring to I'll
simply say this based on the rest
specifically The Book of Romans
especially chapters um 11 or 10 and 11.
um I think it's a very wide all I do I
think we'll be quite shocked at who's in
heaven
at who's given a chance to Bow the knee
to repent to believe uh I think I think
we'll be shocked and why would that be
well
um it's those two little words
freely
and Grace
all are Justified freely by his grace
through the Redemption that came by
Jesus Christ again can you see where the
whole emphasis of the Gospel is not on
human possibility and potential it's
really not on like all right don't worry
someday we're gonna figure it out you
know it it's not really based on that
it's based on what God does
and what God does is cross in the
resurrection this is good news this is
what God does and you you might ask well
like what about
like repentance and belief and faith and
and even all the spiritual practices we
talk about prayer and scripture reading
and like where how does all that play in
you know I think the distinction is just
to remember that those things like it's
in essence it's not about how much faith
we can muster up so that God will save
us it's not about how much unbelief I
can kind of
um build up so that God Saves right no
no
God Saves
and what is belief in Faith and Hope and
practice spiritual practices what is all
that that is a loving response
loving response to the grace
freely given I'll close this is a quote
from a Lutheran Theologian named Gerhard
Ford he said we are Justified freely for
Christ's sake by faith without the
exertion of Our Own Strength gaining of
Merit or doing of works
to the age-old question what shall I do
to be saved
the confessional answer is shocking no
nothing
be still
shut up
and listen for once in your life to what
God the almighty Creator and redeemer is
saying to his world and to you in the
death in the resurrection of his son
listen and believe
so we begin the Linton season
We Begin it here
at the foot of the crust where it's it's
not about how awesome
we can be
it's about what God does
it's about what God does what he has
done for each and every single one of
you what he has done for all of us and
really for the whole world
it's about what God does
so as we come to the table of the Lord
tonight
as we take in his body Christ's body
through the bread
as we take in his blood through the wine
may it be a moment where we lean into
this truth
oh Lord thank you for your grace freely
given
thank you for your love your goodness
thank you that I'll have to keep
striving with all my self-improvement
projects to earn love and approval
ah thank you God for your goodness
and um yeah I pray it's a moment
where um
just between you and Christ a spiritual
a holy moment
so with that in mind we practice what's
called an Open Table meaning if you're
here tonight and you there's something
in you that wants to partake you are
free to do that regardless of like
denomination or exact theology or
whatever just know if something in you
wants to participate then and connect
with Christ then you're free to free to
do that the bread is gluten free the
wine the red is the real wine and the
white is grape juice so
heads up and um we're going to do this
we'll just form one line just right here
and there'll be some folks coming up in
a minute to um to just serve you can
then partake just whenever you'd like
um no one would like lead you through
the exact partaking so
um this is the table
not at the church but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more
so come you who have much faith
and you who have little
you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who failed
come because it's the Lord Jesus himself
who invites you
[Music]
because the cross has the final word in
your life
come to the table
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we're going to close with that song the
cross has the final word one more time
and I think in light of everything that
Brett was sharing for me it takes on a
little bit of fresh meaning
um just the grace that was offered in
that in that sacrifice so will you guys
stand with us if you are finished with
communion or whenever you're ready and
let's just sing that as we go out
tonight
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
because
[Applause]
the savior
saviors
[Music]
as
well the crosses
[Music]
[Applause]
he traded for each other
[Music]
foreign
stronger
nothing greater than the name of Jesus
[Music]
in the name of Jesus
the Savior has come with the Lord
[Applause]
the cross
[Music]
for a reason
foreign
[Music]
thank you worship team and Brett a great
message great powerful words
those of you who are here just do a
quick reminder that we are doing our uh
table meeting I'm trying to remember the
official stay at the table thank you so
much we're doing that tonight online as
I mentioned before it's at seven o'clock
um if you need that link as I mentioned
of course either see me or Brett as you
walk in the door we make sure we can get
that to you
um also if you were a visitor
um we'd love to just take a note that
you're here if you wouldn't mind as
you're walking out the door there are
some cards in the back just fill out
your name and just so we can know that
you're here we'd like to send you a
thank you we won't use reviews any that
information we'd appreciate just knowing
that you're here
and then as I mentioned have said and
many times before if you need any type
of word of encouragement
um a hug a high five or even prayer um
I'll be sitting um in the back for any
of those things or a combination of the
things as well yeah
and with that I want to send you out
with this blessing
[Music]
so you are a child of God
you are a child of God
and that's true on your best day and
that's true on your worst day
so as you go out in your week ahead with
you have to determine highs and lows and
everything in between
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved that you're worthy and you are
accepted Just As You Are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love with
everyone you come in contact with thank
you
there's nothing stronger
nothing higher
nothing greater than the name of Jesus
honor
the power
in all the glory
[Music]
to Jesus
nothing
greater than the name of Jesus
[Music]
with all the power
in all the glory to the name of Jesus
to fight away
the cross
[Music]
ing